-Performing "I Can't Grow Up"
from their new album "Crybaby,"
give it up for Tegan and Sara!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Gimme, gimme
all of your love ♪
♪ And then break it off ♪
♪ Can you even live
with yourself? ♪
♪ Get me, get me
under your spell ♪
♪ Why does it turn you on? ♪
♪ Put me back under the shelf ♪
♪ Take me to the edge,
want the maximum ♪
♪ You're always kiss, kiss,
kissing me off ♪
♪ So lemme, lemme
get what I want ♪
♪ And when you break it off ♪
♪ Get me up
and back to the start ♪
♪ 'Cause I can't grow ♪
♪ Gimme, gimme
all of your love ♪
♪ How do I know when it's time
to let go? ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪ How do I love when it's time
to let go? ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪ Got me, got me
feeling insane ♪
♪ You spin me 'round again ♪
♪ Twist my head
until you hear pop ♪
♪ Get me, get me
under your thumb ♪
♪ Does it turn you on ♪
♪ To hear me
just telling you, "stop"? ♪
♪ Hanging by a thread,
want the maximum ♪
♪ You're always cut, cut,
cutting me off ♪
♪ So lemme, lemme
get what I want ♪
♪ And when you break it off ♪
♪ Get me up
and back to the start ♪
♪ 'Cause I can't grow ♪
♪ Gimme, gimme
all of your love ♪
♪ But how do I know when it's
time to let go? ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪ How do I love when it's time
to let go? ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪♪
♪ Boomerang ♪
♪ Taking my head off, a hitman ♪
♪ Taking my last breath,
sinking fangs ♪
♪ Into my throat,
you're a hangman ♪
♪ Killing my hope ♪
♪ Oh, a boomerang ♪
♪ Taking my head off, a hitman ♪
♪ Taking my last breath,
sinking fangs ♪
♪ Into my throat,
you're a hangman ♪
♪ How do I know when it's time
to let go? ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪ How do I love when it's time
to let go? ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪ How do I know when it's time
to let go? ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪ How do I love when it's time
to let go? ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪ 'Cause I can't grow ♪
♪ Gimme, gimme
all of your love ♪
♪ 'Cause I can't grow ♪
♪ Gimme, gimme
all of your love ♪
♪ 'Cause I can't grow ♪
♪ Gimme, gimme
all of your love ♪
♪ 'Cause I can't grow ♪
♪ Gimme, gimme
all of your love ♪
♪ 'Cause I can't grow ♪
♪ Gimme, gimme
all of your love ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]